c'est un appel main de fois lancé par
volodimir Zelenski mais cette fois-ci le
président ukrainien est venu en personne
au Forum de Davos pour remobiliser ses
alliés face au risque de l'assitude près
de 2 ans après le début de l'invasion
russe et alors que les yeux sont tournés
vers le
Moyen-Orient nous sommes déterminés à
maintenir notre soutien à l'Ukraine et
nous travaillons en étroite
collaboration avec le Congrès nos
collègues européens feront deux même une
aide cruciale car l'armée ukrainienne
est en difficulté
depuis plusieurs mois les Russes
multiplient les assauts sur le front
nord-est notamment vers la région de
koupiansk à une centaine de kilomètres
de carquive bombardé constamment ce
mardi ordre a été donné d'évacuer 26
villages de la région frontalière keV
tient pour le moment mais pour le
commandant des forces terrestres
ukrainiennes c'est la puissance des
armes à la disposition des belligér qui
fera la
différence nos objectifs rest
inchangé tenir nos
positions nos
territoires fatiguer l'ennemi en lui
infligant le plus de pertes possible
mener une défense active en saisissant
toutes les
opportunités c'est ce que nous faisons
au
quotidien l'Ukraine qui multiplie aussi
ses attaques de drone en territoire rus
dans la nuit de lundi à mardi plusieurs
bâtiments ont été endommagés et une
fillette blessée dans ville de von à 250
km de la frontière au moins 5 drones ont
été détruits par l'armée russe et tro
autres ont été
intercepté